hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's 3 now you may be wondering what
else could there possibly be in this
game that you guys need to see well
there's one more an ultimate challenge
the only thing left and if I leave it
alone that I cannot reclaim my crown as
king of five nights at Freddy's and that
is aggressive nightmare mode and I've
done some testing on this aggressive
boat is actually kind of ridiculously
hard but it's my prerogative to do this
and I don't know I'm doing this when I
have very limited time in order to get
to South by Southwest gaming which I'm
going to tomorrow or whenever you see
this I don't actually know I maybe I'll
already be there but if I can just
one-shot this I should be totally good I
don't need to listen to you anymore I
know I've had enough of you fungi I know
exactly what I need to do okay so he's
right there so the first thing that
needs to be done we need to manage this
the defense offense I'm not gonna be oh
well alright then I seem to be slow and
out of control and not able to do
anything that I need to do which is
great for my survival also means that
I'm gonna have a lot of trouble and
things start to go bad because in
aggressive mode you know it's a wonder
he's actually he's actually a little bit
problematic this douche oh [ __ ] did he
just go away I don't know I really
thought that I was gonna be done with
this after this but a lot of people
demanded like over and over and over
sending me emails and wanna say that's
exactly what they sounded like this
invoice wait hang on I need to actually
be able to hear this
I had my volume like way down another
one so he's back here Oh
not again I thought Oh everything's
wrong and a min hit reboot all I'm the
bass all right but I bet I can do oh no
can't do it
ah that's that's problem oh that was
balloon boy about to get me okay well if
you weren't clear on how bad aggressive
mode is gonna be there's a very good
indicator what I'm up against
all right I get all the assume that he's
in five which probably means that he's
gonna be right there okay this is
problems yeah damn it
just give me already I'm ready for you
bunny [ __ ] bastard he comes with his
name is killed boner own he's gonna come
by my window anytime areas hey how's it
going buddy rude Reid bird over here oh
you're over there now damn it God he
slipped I was so fast god damn it he
slips over I know what you're gonna do
hi how's it going
you good I'm gonna go over yes Oh
[ __ ] try to click on the goddamn
button you piece of [ __ ] god dammit
dammit I was trying to click on the
button it wouldn't [ __ ] don't do it
right now how about right now now now
not now I saw you playing peek-a-boo
with me you're such a sassy - I see you
there wonder if I could like somehow get
him to somehow go through the tunnels
all the way back up to cam 9 cuz if that
was a thing dammit he never never goes
back to 2 anymore he doesn't do that I
don't know why he doesn't God he's
supposed to the son of a [ __ ] there was
not a god dammit why did he go to 9 I
gotta keep him in 7 7 is where I got to
keep him 7 and 6 cuz if we can keep him
there then at least I have a predictable
path where it's just gonna loop around
in a circle 7 and 6 god dammit
[Music]
why not compound it foxy oh [ __ ] I just
oh that's what he just what an event he
literally just went in I don't know why
I'm having such a hard time keeping him
over in 786 land
cuz he won't stay there he will not
stand I don't know why yes yeah I used
to be so much easier before he became
aggressive passive-aggressive [ __ ]
right
[Music]
[ __ ]
okay alright [ __ ] get down get down get
down kid goddamn down okay alright you
[ __ ] are you big fat [ __ ] you're gonna
give this to me why god damn it [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] God why why that is
[ __ ] why did Freddie go I've done
that a million times the whole crew in
here come on everybody
you all right great
why why why why why
[Applause]
oh it burns fazbear's fright burns to
the graph that's the same thing as
before Oh
oh god my head hurts so bad I'm not
joyous in this occasion I'm not as
joyful as I was before because I know I
only put this burden upon myself oh I
only checked to see if it was possible I
looked at other people and it wasn't
[ __ ] possible or no it was possible
and god damn it it took [ __ ] forever
oh god oh no oh
okay okay okay hang on one second all
right my camcorder just fell over and
I'm really freaking worried because it
doesn't have a battery and/or the
battery that it has is dead it's been
dead for a long time so what fell over
the power cord got ripped out if I lost
my goddamn web cam files in that goddamn
thing because otherwise you're gonna see
game with my voice over it with our
webcam okay so I'm just gonna assume
that everything is hunky-dory until
proven otherwise cuz I don't know until
I stop and actually edit the video and
all this sucks so much because this took
me two and a half hours and that may not
seem like much well I'm leaving for
South by Southwest tomorrow I did not
have time I saw other people do it
because I wanted to see if it was
possible and they had a great time with
it they did it in like nothing and this
oh oh okay so that is aggressive
nightmare mode that is aggressive
nightmare mode complete legit done done
not that it matters because my webcam
fell over and I could have cut in
between they're like yeah I was I was
doing fascinating no errors radar yep
but goddamn it oh man I really really
really really really hope my webcam was
recording the whole time but either way
okay I need a breather now that this
this is officially the end of five
nights at freddy's this is officially
the end of five nights at freddy's 3 I
have done everything now I could
showcase you guys what these other
things are but frankly I gotta go I got
[ __ ] to do I got wings to see I got all
sorts of crap to do so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
guys so much for enjoying five nights at
Freddy's there may be some fan games and
some similar games of the future but
five nights at Freddy's will always
stand on its own I am tired I'm probably
just gonna edit this and go to bed and
then get up early for South by Southwest
tomorrow but thank you everybody so much
for
watching thank you everybody for joining
me on this adventure and as always I
will see
[Music]